Mike Myers is a fan of our band and his
the music supervisor for his movie The
Love Guru contacted Dan my manager and
um said that they were interested in me
a recording a song for the movie there's
a scene in the movie where they have
this big bar fight and there's a
bluegrass band in the background and
they wanted to record a new version that
that sounded old-fashioned which is kind
of like my specialty so like they want
to record a new version of a Foggy
Mountain breakdown by flattened Scruggs
which is incredible easy clients like my
brother-in-law described it as being
like Louie Louie for bluegrass it's that
like you know it's a standard but anyway
um and they asked if we knew a good band
if we could record the song but we know
a great band the McAndrews as a family
bluegrass band in Western Kentucky that
Craig and my wife Marcy grew up with and
um we got them into Craig studio and
recorded them for the film so it was
awesome and so then apparently Mike and
the music supervisor john and whoever is
involved we're like well Robert recorded
the song it'd be kind of a nice cameo
let's get let's get him to do a cameo in
the film as the banjo player in the
bluegrass band in the bar fight scene so
I got to go to Toronto where they were
filming and I had to learn a little bit
of banjo which was good because I don't
know how to play and like I was like the
banjo player in a fake bluegrass band on
a stage in a bar fight scene and so for
like three days I stood there and played
along with this recording that we had
recorded that with the mckenry's and
like they're like like 50 or more people
falling over the place big burly biker
with young people and like scantily clad
waitresses and stuff like falling and
table smashing and all these fake chairs
Smashing and fake bottles flying is all
fake well actually my real glasses got
broken in the bar fight scene and so
they uh the Love Guru Paramount Pictures
bought me a new pair of glasses these
ones my old one but but it was it was
just a fake fight and uh it was awesome
Mike Myers was cool worked a little bit
on the song together that uh for the
film and um yeah it was an amazing
experience I've never seen a film get
made before it was it was really awesome
i made a lot of friends and i have this
I got to kind of wander around the set
in kind of a privileged position as a
cameo type person and like talk to
different people and find out what their
jobs were and what was going on I got to
see the lots of behind-the-scenes stuff
and it was a it was an amazing
experience